monday Kanye West canceled the remaining
us dates of his Saint Pablo tour and
hours later news broke he'd been
hospitalized according to NBC News it
was for his own health and safety so
what is going on with the rapper a
source close to the Kardashian family
tells ET Kanye had been feeling massive
stress since wife Kim Kardashian was
robbed in Paris quote before Paris there
were a lot of things kanye committed to
work wise that he couldn't cancel all he
wanted to do was stay home with kim and
the kids and he couldn't he couldn't do
it all even though he tried and he just
broke down our source says kim
kardashian was quote terrified at the
news of her husband's hospitalization
she was scheduled to attend the angel
ball event honoring her late father
Robert Kardashian in New York City
Monday night but instead flew back to
Los Angeles to be with Kanye et was at
the event and spoke to Kris Jenner about
Kanye's tour cancellation I think he's
exhausted just really tired
[Music]